Family very one. This is montreality.
To obviously it frustrated forwarding
or it not simply a quay
can your come contracted sponsorship
you see companies here or come to your car key
or to tax the agent?
I mean, whatever they are rising.
Firstly, that's technically legally wrong. Secondly,
physically at the balls are the questions about sorry
concerns many videos made
they can first and foremost option to clear
up
to
get up
the
extension
like a solution gas solution to opco
but like a straightforward
he had K up name employment collage today as employer
slash current jokiaku a real time job
uh, business, uh,
migration can all be options
and Jessica Innovator Founder Visa is a popular one
like it was correctly
as I said, uh,
my previous videos came out tougher to as work
physically any
it's like you all the option had just like a start off
it start up in Isle of Man
both endorsement of nicaraania to Whiskey Threshold
Trust on this patent come a
to get the skill worker visa holder skill
expell your foremost out the option
you have given up an employer
switch career that's employed about giant
take your time.
Switch card agency all visa category
me to applicably sustainable immigration occupancy